[Music]
subject for today
[Music]
sometimes just a classic slurpee that
was it's very tasty yeah
sometimes you don't need to dress it up
it's like a good steak hmm
i don't need burgers no ketchup this is
this is kobe ribeye
we don't need it what i don't know the
japanese apparently they make good
steaks
i'm always amazed at kobe's jose yeah
he was born in japan i think this is
distasteful right on the outside but i
promise you the rest of the show
is as well glad to be with you uh half
asian lawyer is not here audio weight
and
how are you corner black garrett
accepted amongst no communities what a
person
uh token allen and gerald a how are you
sir i'm well i killed asian bill
well that's not very nice don't admit to
a felony on air
especially a felony prove it against a
lawyer
who can now prove that your claim was
fraudulent wait is murder a felony now
i'm not entirely sure it's up there with
not having an n95
jaywalking we have a lot that we're
going to be talking about today so many
of you may not have had the time
yesterday to
watch the arizona hearing yeah uh and
the vote
uh and i know sometimes we'll say well
it's like it's a broken record actually
it's not because we're going state by
state in arizona there are some new
revelations that we heard about
yesterday
that have been confirmed uh it is
confirmed
and uh i think it's important for us to
go over that along with the hypocrisy
coming from the left
on the idea of election hacking think
about this the idea was that the
russians
interfered in the election in 2016.
right and not to mention they also claim
that the russians may have interfered
because of hacking of
voter systems and maybe even dominion
itself
so what what point do you trust him
did you report let me ask you this
people who are watching because we have
both conservatives and liberals
people who are did you believe the
russia hoax did you believe the russia
scandal and now
where do you line up on the on the voter
fraud issue on the
election abnormalities issue i can't say
voter fraud because right away
we are removed it's already under the
value it links to an article that said
voter fraud is rare in the united states
of america yeah you used to say
voter fraud does not exist oh really now
it says it's rare and it says well it
happens but not enough to change the
election
a few thousand is not a mundane detail
michael
uh so but first before any of this um we
just had to touch on this
of course of course it's necessary it's
historical why did you point at me
well because you're into the football so
to promote vanderbilt's play like a girl
campaign that's that's a thing
yeah um it is there was a soccer player
sarah fuller she became the first woman
in history
to play in a power five football game
here you go
[Applause]
history
[Applause]
and the kick down at the 35 yard line
and sarah fuller
happy thanksgiving happy thanksgiving
it's a historic event
i wonder if she did it on purpose i was
like is this an on-site
it should be after kicking she was uh
immediately rushed off the field
vanderbilt lost 41-0 and the coach was
fired
[Music]
yeah the only thing funnier would have
been if they moved throughout i don't
know sports but they moved across the
field
and swarmed and tackled her i noticed
that when she kicked it she actually ran
back towards the sideline and didn't
actually cover what you're supposed to
do as a kicker
by the way if you've seen vanderbilt
play they didn't need a play like a girl
pro
program if they were already doing it
and i know she's already succeeding
wonderfully at that
girls can do everything boys can do
my favorite part i think my favorite
part was that one of the commentators
later on said something like
she did a squib kick which was to the
35-yard line
which was exactly what she was asked to
do
congratulations yeah graduating woman
for doing what she's told
yes giving the team the ball further
down the field is good she had no
business being on that field which is
the same reason that i have a problem
with the film rudy
because he stop it this is not the same
you pick a fight don't you it's
precisely not julia no no no he's the
best yeah
[Music]
quarterback and i lived in the
that's a different yeah says you rudy is
anti-fraud yes
that rudy is rudy was in on the tackle i
want to see that really though what's
funny is we had a girl on my team when
we played
at the greenfield park packers yeah we
won provincials like 60 something to
nothing
and we had a girl kicker she too ran off
the side
now picture that here's here's the thing
when people get really mad at me when i
make
picture that only it's isis it's combat
yeah and a foxhole that's why i don't
want women in combat sure sure sure you
can serve coffees
all right wow uh by the way hey do
follow us on parlor because uh
who knows how long we're gonna be on
other social media platforms and we'll
be taking your live chat on mug club
exclusive
after this love it louder with
credit.com club still the promo code
because the election has not been called
crowder election stream it's 30
off again my question to you is do you
believe
uh did you believe the russian hoax and
has that sort of affected all your
viewpoint of the voter fraud by the way
hit like everyone who's watching
it like like like like like because of
the algorithm on youtube another
quick story before we get to arizona
it's a little bit of a deep dive kids
call it
um is norway has now outlawed hate
speech against
trans people really and people who are
found guilty could face a fine
or up to a year in jail so for private
remarks
remarks yeah never let it be said that
the uh
the norske mountain [ __ ] monkeys never
contribute anything to society
by the way if you do it in public it's
up to three years
in jail yeah in public yeah whoa so
it's not fair it's just like a nice it's
an ikea display
no you have to put them together they
believe in rehabilitation not punishment
because that would be absurd
[Laughter]
so let's move on here to uh to arizona
if you did any of you watched the
hearing and uh what did you think was
the most compelling evidence um
something to keep in mind in arizona
biden leads
leads like girl
power biden leads donald trump by 11 000
votes oh arizona oh
um it doesn't matter because uh well
interestingly enough fox news called it
when trump led biden by
11 million they wanted to be first
yeah so before but there were some
things that were that were claimed
yesterday and i want to say before we
get to the
mammoth possible fraud of the voting
systems right which by the way will also
show you
that in 2016 in 2018 the democrats were
very concerned with there were formal
complaints written up by elizabeth
warren
and uh rachel maddow right well fellow
complaint from elizabeth warren rachel
maddow just bitched on the show yeah but
the point
remains they were concerned about it and
now that was a figment of your
imagination right before we get to that
though there are already
enough issues that can
wipe out the the lead same thing in
georgia right they found 5700 votes and
then you go oh hold on a second people
out of state okay well that's gone
people who are double okay boom gone
trump wins same thing in arizona so
let's start with it's the lead of 11 000
votes before we get to fraud this is
important
uh 2 000 votes they use vacant lots
and false addresses now at first you say
false addresses i should have lived with
that false addresses and vacant
watts what are they ground owls vacant
lots
mcgregor's business in fargo season
three was the address
posted and then 6 000 voters were on the
rolls with
uh no listed sex uh and they just had a
generic date of birth but don't take my
word for it this was in the hearing
yesterday
you have here voted database
discrepancies six thousand voters at
least entered into database
with no sex and default date of birth
and they're non-existent in lexus
correct and i believe uh there will be a
witness to
to discuss that later this morning so
unless those can be
unless those can be discovered those
votes would have to be
would have to be eliminated correct they
also discovered over 2 000 votes that
used
a false address an address of a vacant
lot
correct now were they all the same
things
everybody lives in this vacant lot oh
i'm sorry it was a vacant lot club
oh boy is my face red and leaking
what's with the leaking um it is
it's it's one of those like there's the
rule don't ever ask a question you don't
know the answer to as a lawyer
but rudy giuliani is taking it to the
extreme yes and so
if we do not confirm those votes they
could in fact
not be confirmed correct yes
good boy and that would be a bad thing
if they did this thing if they did the
vacant lot thing so that's that's 8 000
votes
gone gone now i'm not saying that all of
those 8 000 votes were voting for joe
biden but let's be honest i don't think
there are a lot of vacant lot
trump voters it's a niche i've looked at
nate silver's analytics
his deep dives and i didn't see vacant
lot
voters as a key demographic of trump no
i think biden won it 99.9 to
you know yeah the vacant lots one of the
vacants yeah
i think the vacant lot yeah it was
actually a graveyard yeah
[Laughter]
so uh now we move on 143
000 votes um they were dumped at 8 pm in
arizona yeah i think this is after it
was called by the way
fox news a couple hours after it was
called
thanks brett um and there were there
were 143 000 votes dumped at 8 p.m that
actually surpassed the voting machine
uh processing capability again so again
what that means is
we've talked about it with michigan
we've talked about it i think in georgia
it's happened in a few states where
they have a pretty good estimate of how
many votes can be processed in this
machine
and it was surpr you know listen and
it's an estimate yeah i mean like
generally before someone goes to the
olympics let's say you know they say
okay you know what we have a good asset
because the best time of usain bolt like
oh but he was
90 seconds behind we didn't see that
coming yeah
exactly you don't typically outperform
by like 400 right
so why don't we just get a machine and
run some ballots through and
see what happens you know it almost
seems like that would be too rudimentary
[Music]
this is one of those where's bill nye
where are we
going to get a science experiment come
on voting machine
you can't we're crying out can we just
do can we buy a vote and just see like
oh yeah it's right it's [ __ ] there's
no way to process
146 000 votes in zero seconds
only if you try hard and here's
something too i don't know how they
prove this but again these are claims
made under oath yeah and they do it so
these are this is sworn testimony
and then they also have statistical
evidence as well as some
actual evidence that they have from from
screen grabs and videos this is what
they're claiming
but not all of this information is
publicly available tucker carlson said
i wanted i wanted i wanted please no no
hold on we have to wait till it
submitted in court you suck
you won't be on my show because you suck
so i would
i want it yeah let's kneecap everyone
who's doing god's work on
our side because we don't get a scoop
he's making a touchdown
yeah exclusive
excuse me chuck exclusive oh gosh and
they do that weird who wants to be a
millionaire camera shirt
that they don't need that cost them a
crane that's half a million dollars and
i wonder why they're dying
you're dead you should be voting for
biden you're dead so
an estimated we'll show you the clip 35
000 votes this is something that they
claim
was 35 000 votes were automatically
embedded
for every democrat candidate running
here's their claim
so this is a 143 thousand hundred votes
that were injected that was uh in excess
of what the the machines
could have processed uh in pima county
arizona and the democratic party added
fraud votes in the initial count to the
vote by mail totals released at
8pm on november 3rd we weren't aware of
this until
this email until after the fact so there
were approximately 35
000 fraud votes added to each democratic
candidate's vote totals
nothing to see here no but you
we're going to keep going through this
and i know on youtube all i was going to
say is the election's been called
what else you got right yeah what else
you got wajitsuki come on give us
something to go on here we're making
some concrete claims we're staking a
reputation and a lot of people are
you just say nothing yeah and by the way
the guy who claimed the 35 000 actually
turned over
this statement and sent it to the
department of justice and let them look
into it and he said there was a meeting
that he was at they talked about this
he said that they were able to do this
they've done it in years past in 2014
judicial race
where they embed the votes they spread
them out it's like this fully detailed
thing now
it has to be proven it has to be proven
right it's a claim right now but it's
like
it's happened in the past come on which
they say investigate
at least well listen if you say there's
no precedence
as well as no pr and it's never happened
no there's precedence
to have happened before and then there's
also president that would both apply
here you're not bill
you know i was going to claim that you
killed him you put him in a shallow
grave
and he filled out his ballot for no no
no no no no he's lying in an empty lot
somewhere waiting to vote
you didn't even you didn't even dig a
shower why why would i do this serial
killer
always a shallow always a shallow grave
it's because it's lazy you're lazy by
the way
if someone takes me out whether it's
isis or whether it's antifa
do what you want but just i i ask for at
least a mid-level
depth great right a little work and
here's what i'll do for you i will vote
democrat for you for the rest of your
dead non-life well
you'll vote in every election that's all
i ever wanted
nothing would nothing would make me
happier
than to just bust my wife's chops as a
democrat voter even beyond the grave
so this is something again these what's
important when they do these hearings
the reason that they're doing these
hearings okay
is to stay out in front of the public
eye because the media wants you to just
believe there's a coronation that biden
has won
good thing uh that ap doesn't actually
uh elect presidents
we have actually have a process of
electors that go through a state
legislature then we have an electoral
college and people can issue objections
all the way up to january 6. so good
thing it's not ap
or the fox news desk with the crotch cam
it's a good crash game wow wow it is the
crotch line
i worked there and it was called the
crotch cam it's a cam that shows the
crotch it's self-explanatory it's the
crotch
camera does its job
i hope i've clarified for you
so here's another claim that they make
uh 1.9
million mail-in votes and this matters
because i talked about this yesterday
in michigan where i was registered to
vote both in michigan and in texas
i don't think we've had calls back from
the clerks by the way no no i called the
clerk
i called the clerk i called the clerks
to check on grandma ruthie's vote
it turns out that maybe in michigan they
store your absentee voting
tracking status for a little bit of time
and then it just disappears
oh that's what i've heard thus far okay
so but can someone actually confirm
that i don't think my wife voted yeah
exactly i don't think her vote was
counted but here's the thing they also
just sent out
uh ballot requests like we said everyone
unsolicited in michigan
to my old house and they didn't verify
signature they didn't verify signatures
the proper way for example in georgia so
it matters if you aren't verified
signatures because
mail-in ballots when they had to be
requested in years prior they were
rejected at a rate of
30 times what we've seen this election
largely because there were either no
signatures
or they didn't match so in this case now
we have 1.9 million mail-in votes that
were not validated
at all by verifying signatures here they
are the reporting
numbers from pima and maricopa county
merged
election day votes with right end votes
with absentee ballots so there's no way
to
in the publicly available data to
parse those votes maricopa county had
a 1.9 million mail-in ballot request
so and those um
there was a maricopa county official on
videotape that
did say that uh they did not
validate the signatures on the write-in
ballots this year
okay not to short-change information but
get a better ballroom let's go to cnn
really quickly or
two cameras right yeah we're going to be
talking about this a little later on
right now they're talking about florida
governor doubles down
on no statewide mass minute he doubles
down on not infringing on rights let's
see this let's not
disease experts he's gone to the folks
that are most convenient and follow
the ideology he wants to follow and the
result is that he is that man pursuing
his nose faces uh entirely in a single
day
and then at the same time said that
local governments
can't i'd like to get a picture of you
get my profile
well no we want a straight head shot yes
to both
okay this matters because we'll be
talking about it in a little bit
uh florida death rates are going down
illinois skyrocketing
now i know people talk about cases
because cases obviously involve testing
and the more you test and the more
efficient tests are the more cases
you're going to have
florida their deaths have been
consistently going down since summer
illinois
going up so this is something they don't
want to talk about they're not trusting
the science well
listen if he's a scientist and i are
praying to chicken bones like manny
pacquiao it seems to be working
better than chicago right well and these
these stories are related because the
numbers of covet do matter because that
was the
whole reason that we had mail-in voting
right and so the numbers in the mail in
voting matter and the numbers of
covenants
but they don't want us to dig into these
numbers at all they want to just say
it's been decided
the death rate is climbing well the
reason they're afraid in florida
because they usually think it was a
swing state it's no longer a swing state
like well let's try and trash republican
states uh illinois you know what let's
give them a pass
it's just you're not trying to keep
urkel out you're trying to keep out
aerosol particles and by the way can
somebody open like a free like google
drive account so that michigan can
store like two gigs worth of data past a
month accounts are free
no no that's what i said a free google
drive account
so that they could store this data
you're telling me that they couldn't
keep your voting information
more than 30 days they get my national
portion
i just don't it was content it's not no
listen listen and i because i have to be
fair
you're speaking off-pace it's not that
they can't store it it's that they can't
both
store and acid wash it at the same time
that is difficult
to throw back so this is another thing
where they claimed this is a claim that
you've seen repeated by the way which
uh snopes and ap uh i believe yeah fact
checked all as true and no pinocchio
surprising
and that's the thing too is just these
broad claims like they will make
fact checks of donald trump we did this
with lee dorn back in the day where he
went through 50 washington post fact
checks right like he said you know i was
there
in the afternoon they go fact he was
actually there at 6 30 p.m which is
early evening technically but no
fact checks for broadcasting this is the
safest election
ever on record how many times have you
heard that right that's probably the
fact check below this video
which by the way if you're watching this
video hit like right now because that's
what gets us through the fact
it's right above the factory so this is
the claim the safest election modern
history and they debunked that pretty
quickly
by showing that the machines were in
fact they're not supposed to be
connected to the internet which of
course makes them very vulnerable and
they show you exactly how because
again this matters the media will say
there are no receipts let's present
receipts director of cisa at dhs
and he basically said that this election
was the most secure
in history and partially that was
because the
states uh do a uh
an excellent job of validating voter
rolls and that
this equipment is not connected to the
internet the dominion suite user's
manual is about an inch and a half thick
uh in the user's manual uh it tells
operators to connect the ethernet cords
to the router
uh and and it is the systems are
connected to the internet
i one can improve all the cables
from all the tabulators and adjudicators
to
the local data center at the big at the
top
we have election officials that did
confirm that that was connected to the
internet but they said none of the
tabulators or anything else were
connected i can show physical connection
between those tabulator
uh uh tabulator machines the ethernet
cables two routers or managed switches
um but they're it's a router type of
device
and so all these tabulators were
connected to one another all the
adjudicators were connected to one
another the local data center
that they acknowledged was connected to
the internet were connected to these
tabulators it wasn't going anywhere in
the fair yet we did observe
traffic that were going from the u.s now
we don't know if it was
specifically dominion traffic uh going
but to uh to a server in frankfurt
think about this this mirrors exactly i
want to go to your point yours exactly
there is there's no evidence that
there's ever been election fraud yeah
then it goes well okay there was
there is some evidence of election fraud
but it's very very small okay well there
has been some kind of widespread
election fraud but not enough to
actually change the election we've seen
that same thing right here
this is the safest most secure uh
election in modern american history
because the machines were not connected
to the internet well hold on they were
well okay fine but those but the
tabulators weren't connected to the
internet they were hardwired okay maybe
they were hardwired to the internet
but it's not like this was accessible to
frankfurt germany and foreign actors son
of a [ __ ] just stop
somebody else can i get better notes
yeah there is no amount of evidence that
will convince the media and that's why
this battle shouldn't be fought in the
media because it's it's not going to win
it there
right the battle is being fought in the
courts and that's the right way to do it
[Laughter]
no
i should have never ditched the bow tie
can't have it right oh so basically
cnn is still running with sunday's 60
minutes interview with the the former
assistant chief or whatever it's got
whatever his name called or whatever and
saying no no no
none of this actually happened they've
reported zero of this even to debunk
they haven't reported they don't have to
debunk it that's the issue the media has
no accountability whatsoever
that's what scares me think about it
right now not only the media has no
accountability we know that
and now you have an administration if if
biden actually gets in without the
objections in january 6 anyone who
doesn't issue objections who's a member
of the republican party primary them
he's not going to be held accountable by
the media and the media is being held
accountable to no one
and by the way there's this unholy
alliance between
legacy media and big tech because they
now want a stranglehold on new media
because they're
losing that is what is most terrifying
to me
is that we end up like norway where you
can't say kids can't take puberty
blockers without being banned from
society like a black mirror episode go
ahead wait
i was just gonna say cnn doesn't have to
cover it because it's not like
they can go you may have heard this
crazy rumor on facebook you haven't
heard it on facebook because you can't
report it on facebook
you may have heard this crazy rumor on
youtube or on any of the other media
sources
no no they just don't they can ignore it
because everybody has been siloed off
into the smallest news
and then you go to a thanksgiving party
which by the way this is also why they
didn't want you to have gatherings
because they don't even want you to
debate or have these conversations with
your family members
yeah don't have them in the town the
digital town hall yeah also
don't have them in the home and don't
have them in the actual town just don't
have them
don't have them you talk to someone you
go well hold on a second i do think that
this election has been compromised and
your family member goes i think it's the
safest in modern american history you go
what about the 1.9 million that weren't
checked for verification well i haven't
read it well have you
i haven't watched it haven't seen it
haven't read it haven't heard it what
about the fact that there are
over 10 000 votes in states like nevada
or georgia from people out of state i
haven't read it i haven't seen it i
haven't heard it so it doesn't exist of
course
it doesn't exist because it's not on
facebook it's not on youtube
uh and i will say i'm actually very
grateful that youtube just falsely fact
checks us and they still let this go up
algorithms be damned because we only get
the people who actually tune in which
means by the way hit the notification
bell
yes you are subscribed uh every monday
through thursday sometimes friday at 10
a.m eastern because subscriptions don't
mean a whole lot go ahead oh yeah and
unless you think steven's exaggerating
when
sydney powell filed her two court cases
in georgia and you do sometimes
sometimes but in georgia and michigan
twitter would not let you link to the
pdf court
filing it literally would go to drafts
and say
this link is blocked you cannot send it
and i was like oh well nothing to see
here then it must not be true of course
you wonder this is something i know
first let me say i am discouraged
i have not encouraged and i actively
discourage any any offensive
violence okay that has nothing to do
with defending your home and you're
watching your kids if people are hiding
and burning
but do you ever just wonder if we're
that frog in the boiling pot where you
go oh
hold on a second they banned a link to a
legal cape to a complaint
suit being caught they banned that as
misinformation
and then right i mean at what point do
we go honestly they banned
doctors for citing death numbers on
kovid
on on facebook right through doctors
from california
which we now know are accurate because
it went against fouchy
they banned doctors from saying this is
what we're seeing with our patients and
citing actual statistics
do you think we look back and go oh man
we weren't allowed to
not we weren't allowed to stop our kids
from puberty blockers maybe that's when
we should have
stood up and done something yeah at some
point i don't wonder i know
yeah well this is definitely that time
and at the american founding it wasn't
just over
like taxes and stuff there was an entire
cultural divide
and it was just that people got finally
tired of the taxes it was like that last
straw and they were like
this t's gotta go yeah exactly yeah
there's there was a huge divide before
that
right for decades it wasn't about the
twinings
[Laughter]
damn that plays into it
bergamot was a difficult commodity back
in the day
if you saw a bergamot is it a bergamot i
don't know
i disagree i don't know anything about
bergamot outside of earl grey
can someone you know i want to read them
in the chat later bergamot i believe is
a citrus fruit
ooh stay tuned for answers on that one i
would not know a bergamot if i saw it
right now if a bergamot rolled across
this table but it was a
little little cutie oh no it's a
bergamot
bergamot google trends just went from
zero to like yeah exactly
it's an orange like a green bergamot
orange but it looks like a lime
yeah that's weird something shouldn't be
called an orange if it's green yeah the
objective
is incorrect it's been phased out
actually it's not offensive to me i
can't tell
so it's totally fine he positively
loves bergamot i do okay um let's go
back let's move here because there's a
lot to
to continually unpack with each state um
and hopefully we'll get back to you with
some word from the clerks in michigan
don't hold your breath um unless you're
a pearl diver in which case you could
probably do it tomorrow
do hold your breath but something people
don't cover a lot is you know
russia a lot of people think that uh the
russia the russian interference with
donald trump
really it came down to they impeached
the president for a phone call
um a perfect phone call it's very
apparently the best
phone oh advetus and good night
but um i don't know
but but it was about uh was it three
thousand ten thousand dollars over three
thousand facebook ads that's what people
think it was about some facebook ads the
interference
but here's something too a lot of people
don't remember this was being they also
didn't talk about the russians hacking
voting systems right this is not new
this isn't this
before this election it wasn't a
republican or democrat talking point
as a matter of fact it was probably more
often complained about by democrats
because they still they've never
conceded the 2016 election right
still waiting um let's go through this
really quickly so this kind of ties into
the fact that biden announced his pick
for budget chief was neera
tandon is that how i got it near uh who
is the president
for the center of american progress and
uh she immediately began deleting
her uh russian collusion tweets
2016 elections now here is maybe
why because even if you go back then
people like stelter knew brian nuisance
money completely straight stelter
uh talked about how voting machines
could be compromised
um and he was sorry he was the one
saying recently we don't have that clip
right now we have the clips of rachel
mata from before
but he was trying to say that now it's
uh it's a conspiracy theory so this is
their claim now then we'll go to their
claims before
this conspiracy crap is just like
trump's anti-media enemy of the people
smear
it's a slow-acting poison we're talking
about this crippling the american body
politics
slow acting poison like your thyroid
i'm not a good converter from free t3 to
t4
it's glandular i expected him to just
snap at the end
you ever think that brian is secretly
the little piggy who built his house out
of straw
whoa what whoa i don't just mean the
overweight joke though i do but i mean
yeah didn't happen when the wolf is
known for huffing and puffing and
blowing homes down
just like throwing on some reeds that's
good enough he stopped listening it
blowing
oh you're better than that
i'm sorry
[Laughter]
don't blow my house down i'll open the
door
and that third piggy had to be pissed do
you really have to crash a crash on my
couch
for like well you know i don't have a
house you built it out of straw
okay i told you you saw me building it
with bricks at the same time
you pick straw lesson lock the door
uh that's the sore spot for you so that
is a little bit that is brian seltzer
now saying
it's a conspiracy and i think we have
the clip of stelter uh or at least cnn
in 2016
talking about the vulnerability of the
voting machines there we go what are
other ways that this could be vulnerable
these devices have to communicate 2016
database system
we don't know what the transport network
looks like between this machine
and the actual database server so
anywhere along that path
if a hacker was to have something
installed then the
communications could be intercepted
given all this research what would you
say is safer electronic voting or
voting paper well i can tell you this
year i will be voting
via paper with a melon ballot as someone
who is kind of knee-deep in the
vulnerabilities he always sees like
the worst could happen what keeps you up
at night
a compromised election oh
this conspiracy crap is too much i
wonder i wonder if we'll be back you'll
be hilarious if we get fact checked for
that clip yeah this is disputed
don't worry susan wojcicki we've got
plenty more where that came from
because even uh msnbc rep
now they didn't just report specific on
voter fraud in 2016.
so we've gone cnn now cnn 2016. let's go
msnbc 2018
specifically talking about dominion
vulnerabilities oh
we reached out to all nine companies
that you named
their response to the story and they all
essentially echo three main points from
the joint statement signed
by clear ballot dominion voting systems
election systems
and software heart and unison saying
quote voting systems were not hacked or
compromised in the 2016 election well
there's been a lot of cyber security
experts recently saying
there are all kinds of ways that you can
tamper with the either official or
unofficial results
if you can exploit some of these flaws
you go to the companies as i have and
you ask them to talk about this and they
don't want to talk about it
uh uh we reached out for comment by the
way um but suddenly they disappeared so
that's
kind of yeah yeah they closed all their
they disappeared
dominion offices yeah just no more
linkedin no more offices they're just
going to stop
like hey dominion can you well there's
just a dim shaped hole
in the wall like a vacant lot yeah
ah it's just a dominion employee dust
cloud
from where they used to be oh my
goodness gosh
think about that you know what here's
the things here's the thing msnbc
our greatest sin was taking you
seriously we trusted you
you said they were vulnerable we said
you know what maybe msnbc
you know blind squirrel finds a night
every now and then yeah
absolutely i believe that it's
interesting that they came out with all
of these
tales of how dangerous this could be
right after donald trump was elected
trying to so doubt and then in 2018 when
more republicans were elected trying to
sow further doubt and then 2020 no no no
no everything's fine no doubt at all
what we want they're saying
is don't take us seriously which
which time so is that what you're saying
well hold on let's go on to c-span i
don't even know that c-span did this
stuff
i just every time i i just thought
c-span was when there's like an odd
congressional hearing it's like a live
function
yeah exactly
c-span reported on uh how it was a
problem that dominion
and other voting systems um controlled
the vote and this is
c-span 2018. partisan hacks sell-off
part of that those assets to
a third company this is a company
actually based in canada
called dominion voting systems uh so
dominion now
has um part of diebold assets and
contracts
and esns has part of debuld
is contracts and assets in that in your
view yes so uh
so esns essentially uh is you know
maybe controlling the votes is too
strong of a word
but they are certainly um writing the
software for
more than 60 percent of the machines
that are counting votes
in the us how funny would it be if she
was talking that goes to a split screen
it's just a hat gryffindor
i'm sort of in the middle of something
yeah i'm
[Laughter]
this is c-span we don't do commercials
so really unless you go full screen
i just i can't take a sip of my coffee
yeah yeah and was she branded a
conspiracy theorist
at some point no i don't know this was
fact-checked well she is now
sure yeah that's the problem she's a
trump show
yeah they're going backwards deleting
all of these videos as fast as they can
right now
speaking of shill
uh rachel maddow so let's go to
trump apologist rachel maddow who
emphasized how worrisome it was that
russia
could again this is what matters people
just think of russia in the facebook ads
rachel maddow was talking about i think
we actually have a montage because she
did this so much
you're gonna need a montage how uh votes
could be compromised in the united
states uh because of cyber attacks and
our election systems
from you guessed it russia racial matter
far more worrisome to the obama team
was the prospect of a cyber assault on
voting systems
before and on election day
worrisome to the obama team was that
prospect our government had previously
announced that
u.s election systems in the state of
arizona and the state of illinois
had been hacked by the russians
last week bloomberg news had a report
citing three people with direct
knowledge of the u.s
investigation into the matter they had a
report that said the russian attack
hadn't just been a vote against a couple
of states it had actually been against
39 states russian cyber attacks
much wider than previously known much
wider than previously known said trump
apologist rachel maddow listen to him
he knows what he's talking
[Music]
and we just lost nine inconsequential
viewers
are we are we back yeah i think we're
back we're back
just norway yeah we can't be in norway
just like for some reason watching the
late night show
that segment i did with dave landau
can't be shown in japan
it must have been all those japanese
copyright in japan
we do not like her we do not like him
no even if you make a jimmy fallon still
have too much
jimmy farren
so back to the rachel maddow thing i
think
yeah please lovely so i i
she was saying that this is vulnerable
they were vulnerable and they
probably were vulnerable at some point
they didn't have all of the specifics
that we have now right it seems like
he's
not yeah again it was just a suspicion
right it's efficient worth looking into
the hardwired ethernet cable yes if they
had more they would have reported on it
right
yes and now that we do have more totally
no let's bring back up i know we don't
usually do this but uh the first brian
stelter clip
yeah which was uh i got to see it again
yeah you have it so again this is
everything that they have back then we
just went through c-span cnn rachel
maddow in depth about how compromised it
could be
now when we actually have receipts and
we actually have data from the wi-fi
networks being connected and
hardline and even though you could
hardline in 2020 uh
apparently it's this you can this
conspiracy crap is just like trump's
anti-media enemy of the people
it's a slow-acting poison that is
crippling the american body politics you
built your house out of straw sir
that's incredibly convenient for them
that we have
not only that i see this all the time
right now people are saying statistics
don't matter these filings have spacing
issues and who could possibly read this
without
addressing the substance of it at all
but you have you have points of data
it doesn't dominion doesn't have to be
hacked for you to do some research into
this and then you add the dominion stuff
on top of that where it's like well this
is impossible they can't count that many
times can we please look at it no
no you can't why in the world here's the
thing i always the republicans who hinge
everything
on the uh on the statistical on sort of
like the are going to be disappointed
yeah but i do think that it's important
but you don't need that for several
states to switch
right you don't even need dominion it's
already unconstitutional to tell people
a pipe burst and send them home
right when it didn't yeah yeah that's
already bad
that's already bad if you walk into your
house
and you lie to your mother which did you
wear shoes in the house right
no okay that's a problem you get
grounded you just so happen to also kill
a squirrel
yeah because your little jeffrey dahmer
in the making the point is it's bad
enough with what we have you can
already wipe out the margins just based
on hand counting these ballots in
arizona
and georgia yeah and the problem with
arizona is that they would for them to
challenge the electors they would
actually have to have a super majority
to call the state legislature back into
session which they do not have and the
governor already certified it
so we have a huge problem in arizona
where we will likely find out that there
was
massive fraud or irregularities that
caused people to be able to vote who are
dead
i don't like that typically from vacant
lots whatever it may be not a fan won't
be able to overturn it
yes but what you're failing to remember
for republicans in arizona
is those super delegates oh no that's
that's just how you screw bernie
sorry i forgot yeah the other side yeah
the other side
always rigged you guys [ __ ] about
redistricting
can someone explain to me a super
delegate i don't know what it is but
explain it to me without
saying that sounding like [ __ ]
okay explain it to me super delegates
this is the party of transparency
exactly it's a party of there's never
been any voter fraud well there is but
isn't enough to affect it
people should be sending in ballots we
shouldn't have to actually check for
signatures we don't need any photo id by
the way one of the first
actions that joe biden wants to take as
president is a path to citizenship for
11 million illegal immigrants and and
super delegates they their vote just
counts
10 times or 11 depending on how many you
need to be
this is what they mean by democracy yes
so they hacked our democracy yeah that
that's definitely super delegate
services
bernie had one it wouldn't even be by
democratic socialism
it would be by if he had one it would
have been by super delegate socialism
which is really just socialism
oligarchic you just wanted to say that
right yeah it just
is oligarchic a word i know oligarchy
i'm sorry
[Laughter]
fact check the fact checkers i bet
you're regretting your decisions
powell oligarchic tuck exclusive
still hate it should have come on the
show do you have anything more in the
voter fraud anyone want to chime in here
no
okay move on we can move on to uh we can
move on hey look these [ __ ] on cnn
oh gosh okay uh
we're gonna be playing bad movie lines
by the way exclusively behind uh uh for
mug club uh those who are watching uh
loudw talking about another story of a
black business owner who got mad at
twerking but
really let's talk about this pandemic
thing i don't know if it's a pandemic
going on here is it still yeah
really that's right dave the sars2 is a
pandemic
so we talk about this a lot and um uh
well we have talked about it a lot and i
i will say this um
i have family family members and friends
and people who disagree with me and i
have some friends who
who think that this is just something
you know
we have to we have to come together for
the common good people so how much is
your life worth you know what would
change the opinion
of a lot of people out there you know a
lot of people out there watching where
you think
okay it's about it's about keeping
people home now we're going on what six
nine months right if you're really
talking about some places they've been
locked down
plus um okay you just paid a million
dollars in taxes you have a million in
payroll to meet or 15 people are
unemployed tomorrow
go so that change your opinion a little
bit folks
there is no do you have any idea how
much i would love
a covid a co-vacation a co-vacation do
you have a coronacation yeah let's just
i'm going with exclusive about my own
thing yeah give me the idea how much i
would love to be able to take
six months off four months off shut down
get a two-month break guess what
everyone here
out of a job how much is your life worth
how much is the livelihood do you
understand that people fought wars
over less than this because the ability
to hunt that ground oh that's a place
where that's where all the uh the
buffalo are which by the way are hunted
to extinction hey
i'm grateful for thanksgiving that we
took your land so
thanks yeah no more wild buffalo
they weren't conservationists the native
american
painting was colors of the wind my ass
so
they would fight they would kill people
over no that's the land we want to forge
that's the land we want to hunt why
because
being able to provide a livelihood was
your life but people somehow separate
that nowadays how much is your life
worth
you have a million dollars in payroll to
make go
or everyone loses their job jaco willing
has been in war jocko willing has
killed terrorists while seeing the white
of their eyes for crying out loud and he
still gets up at 3 45.
i don't buy it he goes back to bed but
a little napping there's more pressure
on business owners he said
it's because you're dealing with the
livelihoods of many people not just
lives and it's ongoing when he was on
the show he talked about that he said
they're very comparable
here so this is really important to note
because i say that because a million
dollars in payroll that's very typical
of small businesses
yeah or half a million dollars again
people out there who collect a check
from a business owner who you likely
hate
imagine you have to pay out half a
million dollars or million dollars in in
payroll and you just paid a million
dollars in taxes
this is not atypical for small
businesses those are the people
who've had to shutter their businesses
in record numbers
since the great recession likely if this
continues since the great depression
people need to keep in mind but the big
businesses continue to profit
just like big banks just like big auto
just like big unions
it hurts the little guy it hurts the
business owners
the people who make up the backbone of
this country mom and pop businesses and
by the way mom and pop businesses can
still be businesses that are in the tens
of millions of dollars a lot of people
don't have
necessarily some scope you can have a
business that's a 10 20 million dollar
business and the people who own it
are not even in the top tax bracket
that's very common but guess what
the wealthiest billionaires they've
added one trillion dollars
to their net worth and this pandemic
that's a lot
a trillion dollars since the pandemic
started
so we have record businesses shuttering
this is what's also crazy when i was in
michigan
okay i couldn't go to a local i couldn't
go to a farmer's market to pick up a
local squash
i don't even know what that is in the
gourd i don't know what it's washing my
wife's squash
yellow you gotta buy local but i could
go to costco
ah i could order amazon prime and you
can't go to your local grocery store
might have just amazon fresh and jeff
bezos is going
to superman and this is the democrat and
you wonder why
you wonder why the democratic party is
not the party of the working man anymore
they have kept every business owner they
have forbidden them from opening their
businesses they have kept people home
unless they're going out for essentials
pot liquor stores not church
but costco and amazon these are the
people who stand to profit the most and
by the way these are the people pushing
for
these kinds of far-left policies because
it eliminates competition
like bill gates with a baseball bat and
computer companies only now you just
have the government do your job
yeah we used to bring people to court
for this for anti-trust lawsuits we used
to make sure that people could have a
business open and not necessarily have
it shut down for
you know random reasons right and be
arrested for doing something like god
forbid
unlocking your door and letting somebody
in how much is your how much is your
life worth
shut up yeah shut up about this how much
is your life i see this a whole lot and
the people who virtue signal the truth
is
they actually they really don't care
about the people who are being hurt most
by this pendant the person wearing the
mask going how much is your life worth
how many people do you employ how many
how many health care plans do you
provide
to people out there yeah because that
goes away oh okay we'll have the
government do it okay well who's upset
as a government well people who pay
taxes who's gonna ah
we don't know because we've been telling
you for years that billionaires don't
pay taxes they have it offshore accounts
oh so your tax base the mom and pop the
small businesses the people who
they've shut down how are you going to
pay for it yeah
it defies logic but it's also not
compassionate and that's what i'm about
to get to here with some pastors
who i've had my fill of them which by
the way
i never wanted it i never requested phil
it was like someone came out like in new
jersey where you can't pump your own gas
like get away get away get away i can't
i got to pay extra for you to do this
all right okay this state sucks
yeah i was just saying a lot of a lot of
people who are calling for lockdowns
we've been talking about this since
the very beginning of all this the
people calling for lockdowns are the
people with the least
the least amount of skin in the game
people who don't have to pay people
people who don't have i don't actually
wait on their next paychecks
right and and again it gives the light
of the idea that republicans are the pro
big business party
yeah republicans are the pro business
party
but the big businesses they want
government intervention they they want
yeah they want to integrate because
i want to be public
or small business i think we're all pro
good business good business yeah yeah
and by the way i'm no student of history
although i kind of tried to be sometimes
i think the common good has been used by
some very notable historical
figures like lennon yeah yeah i think
pol pot said that i think we
i think inspiration yeah i think
mussolini said that
do it for the common good we have a
common enemy we have to fight again do
it
everybody has to sacrifice so that we
can do this everybody has to sacrifice
listen
we have to see record unemployment and
businesses shut down while jeff bezos
and the malton family
not the ones who shut off the light at
night the walmart family make record
profits because
there's only a 99.998 chance of survival
going without me
go on without me yeah c.s lewis said
that uh among all tyrannies the one
that's exercised for the benefit of its
victims
is the most egregious yeah right and
that
yeah but that's what we call compass
no that's not true just let it ride but
i want to see the comment section lose
their mind
but no it's absolutely true it's
absolutely true and there's
who's the name of this this pastor who
you saw me retweet yeah miroslav
yeah he's the worst name well you know
what i would say i would say that guy
could go to hell but
he beat me to it zing
he's on his way he retweeted this is
something and people were asking me why
did you choose to tweet this because
there are a lot of pastors up i don't
have as much i do have a problem with
all them i should say but i have more of
a problem with people
with shepherds who are leading their
flock
into a wolf pin that's what's happening
right now and by the way just because
you're a pastor and you want to be nice
doesn't mean that you understand the
constitution this is the only time i've
talked about this before this is the
only time in history we have generations
right you have young kids who are trying
to silence free speech on campus who are
fighting for
less rights yeah and this is the only
time where you see the party the
democratic party the champion of the
little man
demanding no rights this is the first
think about this for a second
you have americans the people out there
who are revolting who you are
denigrating who you are vilifying
they're revolting for the right to
go to work
yeah they're not they're they're not
they're not even fighting for the right
to offensive speech so that they can
show up and you know notorious
anti-semite
ben shapiro uh so they can speak on
campus that's not what they're doing
notorious jewish auntie
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's right
notorious yeah but i spotted him yeah
exactly
pure exclusive so this is oh
no they are fighting for their right
to go they're not they're not asking for
a this is a huge difference you have one
side
that is fighting for their right to a
handout that is going to be subsidized
by people who can no longer subsidize
the handout and you say that
billionaires don't pay taxes right yeah
i don't think that's correct of course
they do pay taxes but it's still not
enough it's still not enough if you get
rid of all business you have one side
fighting for the right to a handout from
the side that is
fighting for the right to provide it and
this is what really bothers me with
these pastors the name of the guy was uh
miroslav and he sounds like a communist
yeah he tweeted this out people saying
why did you go after this his tweet was
we are asked to wear cloth over our
mouth and nose wash our hands and avoid
crowds
these minor inconveniences can save your
life your neighbors and the economy
seldom has so little been asked for so
much benefit
and he was i think he was retweeting uh
governor christie and something about
john piper in there who's
he was a dig at piper was it a dick
piper that was a dick it's like it's
even crazier than me
retweeting john piper
here's the thing that's not all
we've been mandated to do right we've
not been asked to put on cloth
and to maintain some distance have you
seen the new guidelines yeah you have to
wear a mask and celebrate christmas
outside
in detroit it's not that would be one
thing
first it doesn't mean that it's
constitutionally correct you cannot say
put this over your face
and uh you're not allowed to go and see
your family you don't have the right to
do that no this idea the right to
peaceably assemble
when some people say do you really need
the same pastor do you really need to go
to church for
uh you know what considering that a
physical church has been important since
the beginning of christianity i would
say so can people do their little zoom
church
i'm sure they can doesn't matter guess
what people have the right to a party
yeah
people have the right to thanksgiving it
doesn't matter what you think about that
denomination it doesn't matter what you
think about the church if people say hey
we require physical worship in
congregation you do not have the right
to tell them anyways if it was a
you do not have the right to tell them
otherwise you said anyways it was like
close and otherwise it's so scary and
yeah this is the kind of guidance you
get from people who actually don't have
any sense of what real danger is right
but go ahead you guys
need to i was gonna say this is not all
that has been asked of us
there has been far more mandated of us
we've been forced to shutter livelihoods
forbidden forbidden you know what how
about this one forbidden from
sharing last moments with loved ones
does that not matter to you do you not
something about christians laying hands
and praying maybe at the final
final moments that's illegal let me ask
you this pastor if your wife's dying of
cancer in the icu
do you skype her because you're not a
shepherd of a flock that i respect if
that's the case when i see people go
after these pastors virtue signaling oh
so little of
i my wife you guys know this she wonder
when a basic procedure woke up paralyzed
from the waist down
i went in to go visit her because it was
supposed to be a basic 20 minute
procedure they weren't even going to put
her under i don't know exactly but they
did
she had a bad reaction to the anesthesia
because my mother took her to the
emergency room
this happened at the beginning of the
pandemic i rushed out of work remember i
rushed i said i gotta go my wife can't
move her legs we don't know what's going
on
and i walked up and they said uh you
can't visit your wife it's only one
person per 24 hours i said okay
i texted my wife and said listen they're
saying i can't come in here
of course that's not true but if i'm
going to be on the nightly news tonight
i probably can't visit you tomorrow so
how long do you think that this stay is
going to be
she said hold on a second turns out my
french canadian mother threatened the
doctor and we were allowed to visit
but i can't imagine people say well i
wasn't allowed to visit my wife while
she was dying
you weren't you weren't they didn't let
you visit your loved one
when they were dying people don't let
you
this is this is remark and you have and
you have pastors
you have leaders of the spiritual flock
going along with this
it's not just about masks and social
distancing it's about removing
our most cherished traditions and
celebrations whether it's christmas
whether it's thanksgiving
whether it's praying over dying loved
ones
visiting family making merry and you're
willing to give that away so you can
tell everyone that you're one of those
agape christians
yeah you know what i haven't seen them
go after either we've seen mosques or
not mosques
that's the one we've seen churches we've
seen synagogues but no mosques and i
want to go to wage point after this the
same the same guy what's his name again
miroslav vol mir stahl slav meerslav
[Music]
i see them you know these these people
and you have the raw bells and the raid
and the uh
there are plenty of churches that do do
things like
just trying to make sure i don't name
names uh
yeah fellowship they tweet things out
these stupid platitudes right now
because right obviously a lot of people
and i'm upset i think people here are
upset about this i was upset when i
couldn't
they wouldn't allow me to visit my wife
if i had to get a battering ram like
the town's people in beauty and the
beast one of belle's dad's contraptions
i was going to be seeing my wife if i
thought her life happened to be in
danger but apparently
the christian thing to do is oh no okay
can you discharge her oh you won't do
that either i get it pandemic let me
zoom you sweetie
last breath but these platitudes they
use i see them say things like
one person was tweeting out again these
are pastors of notable churches i won't
name their names but they know who they
are
people who show the most contempt for
others do so because they truly have it
for themselves
that's such a stew really really george
washington
churchill i can't think of anyone who
hated adolf hitler more than churchill
that's just because it was self-loathing
nazi
this is the stupidest thing i've ever
heard in my life this is the problem
without taking into account weighted
morality christians get it wrong too sin
is sin no that's not true is it the same
sin if you have 50 jews in your attic
too tell them i'd say oh i can't lie 50
jews in my attic or
do you tell them no and you save 50
lives this is a whole other theological
philosophical
discussion that we can get into but it's
not even taken into account
the idea that contempt is somehow
inherently wrong for a christian
this creates a this creates a really
really dangerous precedent for
everything else by that logic
the monarchy they were in the right
because they didn't really have a
problem
with the american revolutionaries
there's no one we're just going to tax
you but we're not going to represent you
it was the people it was the george
washingtons of the world the reveres of
the world who said
you know what we have contempt we have
contempt for you not allowing us to
practice our religion freely we have
contempt
for you uh taxing us without
representation we have contempt
for society that does not allow freedom
it's just because they all secretly
hated themselves
shut up with your stupid platitudes and
go zoom your dying relatives you should
be ashamed of yourself you pop up
[ __ ] yeah and i know another one just
pray for him pray for him because that's
an angry christian
yeah you know what kind of like jesus
with the temple or the fig tree
let's consider that not saying i'm jesus
i don't know enough lawns is it
necessarily righteous indignation but
it's close
this is something else i also see these
pastors go it's about this is something
i see a lot right now too
we're in these in these divided times
it's about a
not about a monologue it's about a
dialogue really where's your change my
mind mr reverend man
because all i saw was you deliver a
sermon about how conservatives who are
refusing
anti-constitutional tyranny are
simpletons yeah where's your dialogue
tired of this [ __ ] i get it i expect it
from joe biden i expect it from kamala
harris who essentially used african
americans as slave labor by keeping them
beyond their sentences
in california prisons i'm sad to say
that now i'm expecting it from
christians and the church
and you know what if you agree with
people who are watching whether it's
live or archive if you're as pissed as
i'm about to hit like hit like right now
and maybe this will get through the
youtube fact-checking algorithm but
oh my god this is this is what passes so
often
as christian cultural engagement right
right so that's the way
but really it's just holding up a mirror
to the culture and saying whatever you
guys believe is what i believe yeah and
then repeating it back to them that's
not how you win people over it and it
also doesn't acknowledge that there's an
absolute contradiction between belief
and
unbelief right and belief is something
that does encourage families to get
together
right that's faith faith is is actually
going and knowing the risks of what
you're doing and stepping out anyway
and doing something with some courage
but there is as long as people don't
acknowledge that antithesis
there will always be there will always
be people that go into
life without faith right without bravery
without courage these are wimps you
can't just come in
and that's a good way to put and by the
way wimp i don't mean that you have to
have big biceps and go out and crush
beer cans on your head
audio weight is someone who you would
think is is more of an artistic
audio wade i know his wife i don't know
his family audio wave has a backbone
audio weight is a brass pair so does
gerald so does quarterback so does
everyone in this room i'm not talking
about being physically tough
i'm talking about telling a nurse to
sorry i know this isn't your job you're
a patsy for the higher ups but you
better move or i'm going to throw you
out a window because i'm going to see my
wife
male nurse mind you male 1 right but i'm
talking about a male nurse yeah
smart i would never hit a female nurse
i'd just tie her up yeah well this is
because you're missing the story in the
bible where there was this famine and
this plague that came in and everybody
shut all the synagogues and they didn't
go worship god like they were supposed
to and they all just said
whatever the tyrannical leader wants
will do absolutely
absolutely not the bible is filled with
stories of people overcoming whatever
obstacles necessary to be able to
worship god
how they see fit people were burned at
the stake in rome they were used as
lights down the street i gotta make a
big thing just use a google hangout
because i don't like you and i could
hurt you
that's why that's my justification at
this point it is
it is absolutely unreal i can't say that
it's unreal i i should be i should be
more eloquent i should be able to i
should be able to articulate myself
better
but when i see this and i see christians
and people who are led astray by this
like
you said it's just oh you know what we
can't uh establish any culture of our
own or make any suggestions as to what a
culture should be
let's just like you said mirror can you
imagine if the missionaries just did
going down there at the aztecs is it
throwing down a virgin girl's head down
the pyramid hey
oh that's interesting that's sort of
similar to the sacrifice of our messiah
we sort of think we sort of think
there's a better way
you know as christians are like into
killing kids or raping kids and stuff
but you know what it's just this is part
of your pagan cult i guess when in rome
we'll try it right the entire reason
that you have a safe society
and a good society is because people
have the exact opposite
strategy yes as what the left-wing
christians are doing right now right
well and so one thing
to be very clear pastors throughout
history have done a horrible job
of standing up in some of the darkest
hours yeah right
throughout history and they have been
looked back upon as cowards
for not doing it and not saying look you
can't tell us that we can't get together
we're going to be responsible we're
going to do the things that we need to
do but you can't tell us
this is a bridge too far we've seen this
over and over and over again and
somebody's going to come on and say this
is not nazi germany
in the 1930s yeah and it wasn't nazi
germany in the 1930s when it was nazi
germany in the 1920s when this stuff
started
all right blame the united states and
the treaty of versailles that's only
half joking we did kind of screw up we
did
it's not a good international policy to
browbeat
don't make any country wear a dunce cap
in the corner
in front of all the other countries this
is true it doesn't turn out good and
they tend to they kind of tend to come
at you with a vengeance
you do you're not justifying any of it
no just saying
looking back probably could have been
some better hands like mistakes were
i think we all think versailles was a
nice idea
okay anyway i just i'm so disappointed
i'm so disappointed with the state of
the uh of the church and these pastors
and conservatives and sam
you know what same thing with
conservatives don't have objections
there is no reason for people right now
people go why do you still
it's like a broken record well first off
we didn't have this information in
arizona until yesterday
right it's the right thing to do you
should have this information
you're not going to get anywhere on
facebook you're not going to get it on
twitter you're not going to get on msnbc
cnn abc
nbc cbs or fox news so guess what i feel
obligated to do it and provide a couple
of dick jokes for some relief every now
and then
and by the way it's not a broken record
when they choose to do the same
illegal stuff in several states and you
report it
broken it's like oh they were same
crimes yeah they weren't creative over
here they did the same thing here that
they did there that they did there
they just keep saying the same prime
over and over again it's like oj
kills again and everyone's like oh
you're going to report this
now okay
if the globe doesn't fit all right get a
new stair so
90s
[Laughter]
okay by the way let's go to uh
uh let's continue as they're talking
right now what are they wait oh wait is
this this isn't cnn this is the right
network
yeah i don't know what you guys did
change it back change it back so i can
get angry
because cnn was talking about uh florida
so this is something that's really
important again when you want to know uh
the meat as to whether the media is
being honest with you listen
we've talked about this quite a bit and
uh by the way all the sources that we've
provided today are available at
lighteroscrider.com
the link is in the description uh below
or i don't know where you're watching
this you can just hit
so you watch it natively on youtube so
we actually provide all these sources uh
for you
um we've we've talked about different
states and how obviously blue states
have not done as well
as red states both economically
obviously there's no debate about that
but the thing that the left doesn't
really want to talk about is blue states
with these severe lockdowns have done
far worse
uh as far as mortality rates
particularly states like new york
i mean john johns hopkins had to remove
a paper because it said that the death
rates weren't really all that
dramatically increased
uh for covid in 2020 versus 2018
and here's the thing if you look from
2019 to 2020 it did increase
overall yeah but you can attribute it to
four states and i won't tell you which
how long you're going to do your own
research yeah four
states something about nursing homes and
crips i don't know
but illinois kova deaths right now they
are spiking so i want you to see you can
see this chart under the uh democrat
governor look at that chart that's a
that's a hockey stick chart governor
j.p pritzker that's just a layup that's
no good
yeah don't do that now let's contrast
that because you're seeing deaths go
up now we've talked it's not just about
case deaths are the metrics that matter
because
well i was going to say there's no way
to cheat them there are ways to cheat
death
through votes or you're just listing a
death as covid
even if it was a shotgun blast to the
head or a guy who drove off an overpass
drunk on a motorcycle
we get it there might have been some
antibodies in the system
that's one for you sarge too
[Laughter]
but let's contrast this right now
death's going up if you're in illinois
you should know about that if the press
is not the enemy of the people if their
goal is to keep people safe
obviously it's not to inform people
let's assume there's still a job of the
press to at least keep people physically
safe you know
some like they can't be entirely
replaced by an amber alert on my phone
let's contrast the spike and death
they've never talked about here on cnn
illinois
with their current coverage of florida
what you've seen from desantis the
governor of florida is essentially a
lot like trump just sort of ignore the
problem we can handle it
not a big deal no statewide rules no
statewide orders
um and then and then you start to see
the numbers is that true thinning elvira
she went vegan deaths have steadily been
going down
yeah in florida since summer and yeah
and florida has been far more open
than illinois illinois had stricter
lockdown measures and illinois is seeing
a spike in deaths you look that's the
deaths
down in florida up in illinois why are
you still talking they're talking about
florida not doing
enough to lock people down what they're
not covering is that something
they're doing in florida is working to
lower deaths yeah
week over week what they're not what
they're doing is they're praising
illinois
for removal of rights because that's
sort of their shtick
yeah get it get a new bag they're
praising them for the lockdowns
but they ignore the crazy spike in
deaths
yeah and their economy is doing better
florida florida is yeah
illinois is treating covet as if it's
the only factor that is worth weighing
and florida is treating it as one among
many factors
right and the and the people who are
treating it as one among many factors
are doing better with that factor
because they're weighing all of these
factors
and by the way if you uh weigh brian
stelter do it in a truck at a weighing
station
yeah yeah well this was that clip we
just ran was from the summertime when
they were preaching
the gloom and doom of what florida was
doing how dare they
open up as as a state right now and they
haven't gone back and covered it and
gone oh well hey we were wrong they
haven't gone back at all to florida to
say
well these numbers actually don't look
all that they haven't gone back and said
we were
wrong to put young covid patients in
with old nursing home residents no
no accountability not whatsoever they
get it wrong no one calls them on it
that's why we'll keep doing what we're
doing and you know what if people don't
if people don't like some of these if
they think that it's repetitive that
we're covering arizona today that we're
covering the voter fraud
once we'll stop covering it when it
stops happening or when it's
acknowledged
just like we'll stop covering the actual
facts surrounding kovid
either when we're banned or when they
stop lying about the facts
and i i will say this it's not a mistake
these are lies no yeah absolutely and
one of the crazy things is that they
come out and say i can't believe
that people think the election was
stolen i can't believe they don't trust
us anymore when they do things like this
they come back and are genuinely shocked
that people don't trust their bull crap
anymore
yeah the problem is the problem is
there's still a lot of people who do yes
like what's that uh pastor's name
miroslav
yeah he buys that he buys that [ __ ] this
is more pressed than he's gotten ever
well this is true yeah and more
mispronunciations than he's got never
which that's just in general any any
any pastors and preachers who run in
those circles
guys you gotta you gotta reevaluate your
leaders
i get that it sounds nice you don't have
the right to tell someone else to shut
down their business that they can't
visit their loved ones i don't care if
you think that's agape love christianity
and you ignore half of the bible
it's still it doesn't apply biblically
it doesn't apply
theologically and it doesn't apply
constitutionally
here in the united states of america
that's what bothers me because people on
cnn those hell-bound heathens of course
we expect them to get it wrong and not
take into account
a higher uh accountability a higher
power a higher virtue
other than having an [ __ ] haircut
like sanjay gupta trim the rat tail for
crying out loud we get it you're not
going to a barber
social distance good yeah of course we
expect that from cnn we expect them to
not understand
the the the value-based judgment from
the
christian side the higher power the the
spiritual side of this but the problem
is i i guess
i never expected those who are supposed
to be uh spiritual academics
to not take into account the
constitutionality or the
historicity is that the proper word
and what you need to have all of these
portions of the equation
and i i guess i thought that the leaders
of the christian movement
would i expect this from cnn yeah i
expected better not from there
right and what yeah and if you care
about your flock what about the
increased
suicide rate because people are
depressed what about the increased
alcohol
domestic abuse what about what about
mental health issues that people that
are under 20 are now suffering in record
numbers because of these lockdowns those
people i think are are part of your
flock i think those are the people that
you said there's lives matter show me
when someone comes in
a mass shooting with an illegally
purchased firearm and then we'll start
talking about mental health of course
yeah another little tidbit miroslav volf
made a name for himself by
saying that christians and muslims
worship the same god and we're all on
the same side
oh good you know martin luther and
nail the charlie hebdo cover to his
congregation
there you go all right right now it's a
it's a joke it's a joke don't do it i
know you don't take that as a death
threat but that's not because i
threatened anyone
it's because you know muslims kill
people over that [ __ ] that's true hey
you know what you can nail
nail as many pictures of jesus as you
want white jesus mediterranean jesus
black hebrew is your light jesus
i don't care no one's gonna die because
i understand your rights we're going to
go play bad movie lines and talk about
illinois a little bit more
right now youtube i've had my fill with
you
it's off
you